okay that's the least of my worries in
episodes 1 2 and 3 by the way oh oh
you're talking about George Lucas and
now he's been completely seduced by CGI
oh this is a new shirt are you kidding
damn Dam oh c oh that's this is look at
this it's like I got two little paint
titties on my shirt
[Music]
now what are you looking at h
what dude my eyes are up here yeah
eyes dude what are you doing it's paint
what are you doing come on we've had a
good time today haven't we we hung out
the whole day it's paint paint it comes
off see see how that comes off huh yeah
yeah yes oh dude stop it just stop it
you want me to stop then stop licking
your little titties they're not real
titties really twice unbelievable hello
[Music]
ladies to the man of the hour guys best
bachelor party
ever oh yeah yeah
the stuff I can still do it all right
fellas what do you say we get a
strippers am
right Trey I told you man no strippers H
is this a bachelor party or isn't it
that's I'm say I'm your best man there's
no way I'm going to let you puss out on
your own bachelor party we getting a
stripper and we going to connect the
dots yes connect the dots yeah Tinker
toy it man you're behind her and then we
all bu we go to town to town wait hold
on wait what's what's what's bu bu dude
you know you're up front then bu bu game
on no hold up hold up hold up hold up no
what's the bu bu bu bu yeah yeah what is
that guys this is Tommy's last night of
fre fre yeah come on what what's bu bu
though you know b b b b okay okay okay
when you say bu bu B are we what are we
are we all Linked UP yeah baby elephant
walk woo okay okay okay um are are you
saying that that we would we would all
be each other you don't understand what
I'm oh dude okay look here it is is okay
you're the girl right right right yeah
then we bu that's it right there yeah
yeah what the I'm not doing that you
guys Tommy's about to walk the plank of
marriage all right this is our last
chance chance for one I'm not going to
the guy yeah no dude we'd all be the
girl
together see but right there right
that's the weird part The Bu B okay I
get it I get it you don't want to be
disrespectful to women I get that not
the issue forget the girl Armenian
conveyor belt just the groom and his
groomsman B no you kep the part that
nobody wants the yeah I definitely don't
want to have sex with any of you guys
yeah you're killing my buzz guys what
the man this is supposed to be Tommy's
last big celebration no judgment
judgment is not what is keeping us from
each other
jeez forget it TR no I'm saying guys if
you listen to my words Tommy's in here
stripper we're in the other
room nobody wants a okay fine no B okay
no B you're here the stripper the rest
of us you just Jiggy Jiggy Jiggy Jiggy
Jiggy oh my God you guys are so gay hey
girl I'm home hey boo how you doing good
how is work sucked a can I ask you a
quick question yeah sure what up i' just
been noticing that every time I leave to
go out the next time I open the computer
the browser history's been
cleared hm that's weird yesterday I went
food shopping for like 15 minutes I used
the computer before I went to the store
and when I came back my history was gone
the cash was cleared and the cookies
have been reset
huh well I think sometimes the computer
runs an automatic software update so
maybe that just kind of clears the
history yeah except when you update the
software a little window pops up and you
click okay and then it gets installed
so
hm I don't know maybe there's something
wrong with the computer you know and
it's just one of those things whenever
it getss interrupted from the power
source it has to reboot and it just
totally wipes out the
history be honest babe it's porn
right porn what's oh pornography no it's
okay if you look at porn I assumed you
did anyways I mean every guy does I'm
perfectly okay with that as long as it's
not that weird
stuff oh all right well I mean kinki
okay I like kinky as long as it's not
that sick twisted SNM
stuff wow
um okay I'm not going to judge your
journey it is your fantasy just as long
as you don't looking at women
who not women wow okay men chicks with
dicks horses worse than horses
wow baby give me a little
credit none of that matters the only
thing that matters that when we're doing
it I'm thinking about you and you're
thinking about me
right right
[Music]
baby
oh hi that wasn't expecting to see you
all undulating up here I I just uh put
my jacket on the bed when I first came
to the party but uh I didn't realize
that the party made its way up here but
I'll get that now I will if you uh a
Carol I don't know if you're in there
somewhere but uh wherever you are thank
you for the invitation I really enjoyed
myself I'll see you at work tomorrow
okay Hey sir I think I see my jacket I
think I I think your arm is in the
sleeve actually I'll grab that's not my
jacket and that's not your arm it's not
your arm white people are crazy white
people are crazy just looking for a
jacket sir okay yeah very nice mustache
I've never seen one above the nose
that's interesting that's not your nose
okay sorry to uh disturb you sir just
looking for a jacket just a ordinary man
looking for a jacket you want to say
something to me sir are you oh no thank
you very much sir it tasted a little bit
like salted but but that's okay it's
Tweed the jacket I'm talking about and
it's got leather patches on it just oh
maybe this is it thank you found it and
nope that's not it but congratulations
ma'am you are doing great with what God
gave you nope don't look at me in the
eyes ma'am I don't want you to steal my
soul hi ladies and nice to meet you and
sir yes I do see YouTu okay yes white
people are craving oh no I'm I'm okay I
really am I'm uh already seeing a a
group of people and we're taking it
slowly we are taking it slowly it's a
church maybe some of y'all would be
interested in looking into that not mine
but one somewhere if that's okay thank
you ma'am for there it is I found it
found the jacket it's right here I'm
going to pull it and I believe it might
be lodged somewhere within you I'm just
guessing because that is just a little
bit of resistance all right there we go
and you know what that is going to be
yours keep it thank you cover yourself
up Carol if you're in there I'll see you
at the office tomorrow just bring the
bowl you can finish the the egg salad my
God why people C what up homies welcome
to C class I'm shabo Michael I'm T
Tombstone and we're here to teach y'all
how to go down on [__] right now
[__] ain't being satisfied so check
it quit fing on that clitorus so damn
hard [__] don't like that nonsense
that's like putting the tippo penis in
the vacuum y'all need to chill on the
clitteris go around that business that's
like a button made of a million penis
tops now every [__] like her cing is a
little bit different vaginas are like
snowflakes snowflakes is different learn
your [__] snowflakes ask your [__]
what she wants then do what she says
some [__] like it in a circle some
[__] like it up and down some [__]
like it hard some [__] like it soft
communicate with your [__] make the
alphabet with your tongue A B C D and
when she grab your hair like she going
to pull your damn head off stick with
that letter I'm talking
about vaginas deserve respect you don't
want someone slapping around your little
homie you with the hat yo how you like
your BJs damn dog all the time shut the
up that's cuz penises is easy and
vaginas is hard they
confusing imagine there's an explosion
at the envelope Factory flaps everywhere
a world of flaps and you need to lick
your way out the factory but every
bitch's flaps is different learn your
bitch's particular flaps flaps be crazy
crazy every flap need to be listened to
and then you will get out of factory
alive stay down there plan your
breathing like your swimming got talking
about stroke stroke breath stroke stroke
Brea all right let's take a 5 minute
break when we come back we won't talk
about warming your [__] up before you
get busy and that'll last for more than
two damn minutes take a peach and
practice practice on a peach take a
peach and practice practice on take a
peach and practice practice on a
peach well I think it's going to work 30
d down 3 billion to
go it's a weird one nothing out of place
no murder weapon and no motive there's
uh just a couple lying dead in their bed
the proof is always out there
detectives you just have to know where
to find the pudding excuse me sir you
can't be here this is a crime scene it's
okay he's the greatest sex crime
investigator in history if it isn't
detective Chuck Von detective Sally
Ferguson we could use a genius right now
Tom
Samuel what have we got Samuel well uh V
we've got ourselves a hard case here all
we've got is two bodies both dead naked
one man one woman in the bed two scented
candles by the nightstand how did you no
sign of forced
entry he loved the way they
smelled he wanted to cross the threshold
the way they had on their wedding
day you dirty
dog he would have experienced that
pleasure right
here anniversary a couple was together
for a while wanted to spice things
up check the date on the
photograph
V's right today was their 15th wedding
anniversary this is huge
and what the was that you just pulled
your dick out and started jerking off at
the crime scene Samuel he's the best
there is by putting himself in the
perpetrator's mindset he's able to solve
crimes that involve sex bag this up some
call it a
blessing it's more like a curse is that
what it feels
like three
[Music]
some you wanted to see them didn't you
you wanted to
watch 25 ft from the bedroom cross from
the
[Music]
kitchen you didn't want to see their
flesh yet did you no he
stood right
[Laughter]
here
a role play Gone Wrong check the
logs we've got a bloody fire poker we've
got our murder weapon um why do your
Revelations require masturbation why do
kittens require milk no not the same
thing hey hey
he's the most brilliant goddamn
detective I know put your ego aside and
give Von a space my ego we've got
Captain P puller flinging his fluids all
over the crime scene wait he knew
them they were close so close too close
he
he I think he knew the
house
why what you want you sick
bastard he wanted to
see what he saw every
day only
Closer
[Music]
Closer he was close to
home
there's a
man all right let's go get him go
go
vau that was amazing I'm sorry that I
doubted you your methods are unorthodox
but I cannot argue with your
results no hard feelings uh no no not
going to do that go to see old boy how
was Kenya I love Kenya absolutely adore
the place you know it's so important to
protect them you know oh yes the few
untouched tribes left indeed yes and
while we're on the subject I've got
something of a confession to make oh
dear while I was down there I caught the
attention of a young Messiah woman you
didn't she took me for an exotic
sophisticated Superman of sorts and
developed something of a liking to me
well isn't that always the way yes it is
and it was quite awful Gerald she came
down to my Hut wearing nothing but a
fertility headdress and carrying a
husband stick and oh I had to
participate in the custom well you'd be
morally irresponsible if you did not
participate in the custom you could
destroy the entire social structure oh I
felt so terrible about what of course
you did Gerald I felt terrible seven
times but you know Gerald I too have a
confession do tell remember several
years ago when I went to the Amazon yeah
yes well I accidentally pecked a lighter
in my SEL oh my yes well one day I
absentmindedly lit the Flint and the
entire Village took me for a god oh no
yes every Sundown as I was being fated
by all the young women of the village
which is the local custom I felt
completely embarrassed by the entire of
H I can only imagine in some vivid
detail but you can't deny the local
custom you absolutely cannot deny the
local Customs loal you cannot deny the
local Customs one thing you must do is
that here to the local Customs must the
local
Customs the local Customs local Customs
local C it's oh the least one can do it
all reminds me of the time I was in Papa
New Guinea and I introduced the local
tribe to the French term manaja after
that evening a couple of the local men
called me Papa oh dears
da whoopsy Daisy indeed it's getting
harder and harder to protect the local
tribes from the influence of the outside
civilization I know exactly what you
mean oh boy exactly and I must confess
that the last time I was deep in the
bush in Australia yes I ended up deep in
Bush in Australia booah well what are
you off to now old boy I'm off to
Tanzania tanzia make sure that you go
during an eclipse because then everyone
will want to have sex with
you
regrettably tit TI
[Music]
what if we told y'all that once a month
half the human race is in pain and the
other half don't want to hear about
it b t Tombstone welcome to menstruation
orientation oh no you don't we know you
don't want to hear about it but they
don't want to have it so sit your ass
down and listen for once in your life
today we going to talk to all you men
about what happens to your women when
they on their periods and why it's
important to be sensitive to that don't
say chillax relax calm down and how
don't say ass fat grumpy or cranky they
ain't cranky they got blood coming out
of their vaginas yo that's some biblical
plague y'all that would be like once a
month if you had Locust flying out the
addiction for a week your ass wouldn't
be cranky your ass would be
like What's
happen so be nice to your [__] when
they bleed in if you ain't getting them
get the out they way they got crbs they
got headaches they got weight game and
every time they pee it's like the
shining in the toilet be supportive be
empathetic but whatever you do do not
try to solve it don't even bring that up
when women be hanging out together their
periods will sink up vaginas be
communicating they got their own vagina
language talk
[Music]
about
man if you find yourself around a group
of women and they all have a back ache
back away slowly what's that in your
pocket there soots recognize this mother
that ain't space Dynamite that's a terod
learn what your [__] has to go through
first you put this piece in your vagina
then you push this part into the first
piece then you throw this part away do
that several times a day for a week
every goddamn month it's the worst thing
ever all the time it's much worse for
them than it is for you to hear about it
and periods is important that's how the
body gets rid of the old eggs so it can
cook up them new ones so listen to
what's going on with your female
emotionally and get B some chocolate
don't call her a [__] but get B some
chocolate chocolate chocolate choc choc
[Applause]
[Music]
choc but I don't need you